foreign
is with us in Sacramento we were just
there hi Marie how are you
I'm good how are you guys better than we
deserve what's up
um my husband and I are having a
discussion about paying off our mortgage
um this is our situation he is active
duty military we know that we'll be
stationed here
um for about three and a half more years
but then we'll be moving to the Midwest
so we're trying to figure out if we
should pay down the rest of our mortgage
like as aggressively as possible or
should we invest that money for a future
down payment at our next TV station
you're going to sell the house when you
move
so either way you're going to get the
money back
it's not like we're spending it
right
no I mean you're either going to put it
in an investment or you're going to pay
down the house either way the money is
going to be sitting there when you move
and going to come out of the investment
or come out of the house and be used for
the Midwest house correct
yes okay so I think if you get that out
on the table and say that out loud
sometimes that changes the way it sits
in your brain
because sometimes people feel like when
they're paying off their house that like
they're spending money or something it's
not going away you get it back when you
sell the house
so you're making the interest rate as
your rate of return because when you
don't pay interest on it you save that
interest right by paying it off or
paying it down either one or you make
the rate of return on an investment the
difference though is is you can cash out
an investment by a bass boat you really
can't do that with your house
it's what we call a forced Savings Plan
once you pay down the house you are
stuck only two ways to get that money
out refinance which you wouldn't do or
sell the house which you don't do until
you move so keeps you from spending the
money and you get a rate of return and
you're moving towards wealth I'm paying
down the house
okay
my opinion as well bye but um you know I
thought I would call and get your
opinion just so I could have that to
talk to my husband yeah and and here's
the weird thing too after doing this for
30 years
sometimes people's plans don't work out
can you imagine that is true
yeah and I don't know what series of
events would occur for you to remain
there
I don't know what those would be uh or
to be delayed there for five extra years
or to move sooner because something else
happened I don't know what any of those
things are but seldom have my plans that
I laid out worked out exactly like I
thought they were going to my never do
day and never well that's what my that's
kind of my point none of them so yeah
I'm paying it down because that works no
matter what happens so there's this fear
permeating the uh the interwebs that if
you pay it on your house now it's going
to be worth less than three to five
years
the house values are not affected by the
debt on the house
say that again the house goes up in
value based on what someone will pay for
it not based on what you owe on it right
but the fear being if I pay off my my
mortgage in at 600 000 and suddenly have
to sell it for 400 I've lost two hundred
thousand dollars you you've lost it
anyway because if you if you haven't
paid it down and you sell it at a loss
you've got to pay the difference
you should start a radio show Dave
but that's not what they say on the
internets man I know but if you at least
I know I know exactly what it is if you
owe 500 000 on the house and it goes
from 600 down to 400 you owe a hundred
more on your house than it's worth they
don't give you a break on it and so the
illusion of having a hundred grand in
the checking account is the Hedge
against that isn't real it's not real
they're gonna take that money you know
this is why they should teach you know
basic accounting in the 11th grade but
they don't that's called a balance sheet
entry so oh god
um the internet hey that's what he was
asking the Internet is just oh that's a
Suzanne no no no he's just saying he
wants the money easier to access so when
they move they can just do the move and
then he's going to try to buy the house
in the midwest before he sells the house
in Sacramento and I'm going to prevent
him from doing that because he's not
going to have any money gotcha because
he's going to tie it up in the house
he's got to sell the Sacramento house
his house and not going to say we're
going to keep that one as a rental while
we moved to Kansas City no we're not
either selling that dadgum thing
and it does not change the value of a
home whether you pay it down or not
that's a different issue but yeah both
of those got covered in one call look
how good we